اا نتنياهو قال للرئيس الاسرائيلي بانه
بفضل الجهود التي تم بدلها تمكن من تشكيل
الحكومه وابلغه بذلك رسميا وقال له بانه
سيقدم له هذه التشكيله في الاسبوع خلال
الفتره القريبه مع بدايه الاسبوع المقبل
وبطبيعه الحال الاكثر رئيس هيرتك على ان
هذه الحكومه يامل بانها تكون في خدمه كافه
الاسرائيليين التفاصيل غير واضحه حتى هذه
اللحظه ولكن وفقا لما يرد اتباعا بان حسب
الصحافه الاسرائيليه همم بان بنيه يقدم
للاحزاب التي تتشكل منها حكومه وهي
بجميعها متدينهه ومتشدده المطالب التي بها
وكانت سببا في اعاقه تشكيل هذه الحكومه
حتى الدقائق الاخيره وعلى راسها تمسك
رؤساء هذه الاحزاب نتحدث عن حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه شاس اليه كل هذه الاح حابه تمسكت
في مناصبها وقالت الصحافه الاسرائيليه
بينما اعاق هذه التشكيله هو التشبه في
تفاصيل هذه التشكيله واصرار هذه الاحزاب
على توقيع اتفاقيات مفصله الذي اراد ان
يكون هناك اتفاق عام مع كل هذه الاحزاب
دون الخوض في تفاصيل دقيقه اعلان هذه
تشكيله وهذه الحكومه ولكن على كلن نتناهوا
بلغ رسميا هناك حكم اسرائيل قد كشكل